I think I've made it no secret Rachel
that I don't like musical artists Kanye
West I find him off putting I find him
revolting I find him self centered and
pompous sort of like Donald Trump
actually now that I'm thinking of the
adjectives that I'm using their will
trump and Kanye met yesterday at Trump
Tower to talk about life now as a
reminder Donald Trump is too busy with
other stuff to take daily intelligence
briefing something that every president
has taken daily Trump doesn't need to
because he's smart and he's also really
busy but he had time to meet with Kanye
here is video after their meeting where
again they were just talking about life
[Music]
just friends his friends and it's a good
man doing well long time we've been
friends for a long time
life you're disgusting
I am
I know calm environment election today I
just want to take a picture right out I
I just find him so off-putting the way
he just smirks and stares at people
asking questions without even say I just
genuinely don't like Kanye West and
after admit Rachel was kind of bumming
me out before the show she's talking
about how she really likes Kanye and I
mean do you want to comment on that
Rachel I was getting a little sad I do
like his music I don't really appreciate
the Free Association nature of all of
his rants and rest speeches he actually
has tweeted out why they were speaking
not just about life but about
multicultural issues that yes bullying
and violence in Chicago where he's from
and modernizing curriculum so i think it
was it was probably very productive is
this another one of trumps ways to
distract from issues like the insane
conflicts of interest between his
company and the looming presidency or
the growing realization that a foreign
power russia helped him win Kanye West
reportedly left a recovery program to
meet with Donald Trump but according to
trump spokeswoman hope Hicks it was
actually Kanye West who had requested
this meeting and requesting a meeting
with the president-elect does sort of
fit into a string of erratic behavior by
Kanye West he abruptly cancelled the
tour in November after a number of
really weird concert appearances he was
hospitalized in what was characterized
as a quote psychiatric emergency and
then in one mid concert rant a few weeks
ago he voiced support for Donald Trump
and then ended the performance much the
shock and disappointment of his fans and
you might remember III never talk like
talk about Kanye West so infrequently
that anytime I do I have to remind you
of this you might remember that Kanye
has been sort of involved in politics
for a while because one of my favorite
political celebrity moments was when he
said during a post-hurricane Katrina
fundraiser that George W Bush doesn't
care about black people remember this
and subtle but in even many ways more
profoundly devastating as the lasting
damage to the survivors will to rebuild
and remain in the area the destruction
of the spirit of the people of southern
Louisiana and Mississippi made up being
the most tragic loss of all
George Bush doesn't care about black
people please call yeah right past few
days where the most bizarre telethon
fundraiser moments in the history of
television no doubt uh the that what's
gold about that video is if you only
heard it you don't realize that number
one Mike Myers is on camera there with
Kanye he looks completely confused as to
what the hell is going on and then they
cut to Chris Tucker in what clearly also
surprised Chris Tucker and he doesn't
know where to go with it either that is
one of my favorite telethon moments
period Rachel I don't know how it ranks
for you I would say it's a hundred
percent number one because you cannot
write anything like that I actually
heard that Kanye is being considered for
the surgeon general position I know it
doesn't sound like something he'd be
able to do uh but you know a
neurosurgeon is going to be heading up
housing and urban development so it's
not that far-fetched for Kanye to be
Surgeon General he can only get that
position if he hates surgeons yeah uh
maybe Secretary of slow jams a reference
to his collaboration with Jamie Foxx
it'll be a new position created for
Kanye West no time for intelligence
briefings plenty of time apparently for
Donald Trump to talk about life with
Kanye West uh discuss this and any other
stories you would like to discuss from
today's show on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash reddit that
is re d di t we'll take a break back
with more after this warby parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / tdps I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the sales person sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby park
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing